我现在已经讲了将近一个小时20分钟了
那我今天我不知道两个小时能讲完
因为接下来sky这个东西啊
真的是就是让你又爱又恨
我想跟大家大家先爱一爱啊
先这个就是打打气
天空真的很美对吧
我觉得就是一个游戏啊
它的整个一个氛围
我觉得天空和他的这个语音实际上起了绝大部分的这个影响力
真的你的情绪很多时候就是夕阳残雪对吧
我的情绪就上来了
那比如说像这个horizon有一点那种异性的这种感觉
比较a脸的这种感觉
那么包括像这个老头环对吧
人家是特别善于刻画这样的一种情绪和气氛
对
这也是阿里特别特别喜欢的一个东西
那么回到我们去表达这个sky的时候
你会发现它里面有两个元素
这一定要分开来
一个是什么呢
一个是天空sky对吧
就是大气
你看到的大气是什么样的
然后在大气层里还有一个东西很重要的东西
就是特别visible的东西是什么呢
是cloud是云
天空和云是不能混为一谈的
因为天空它是一个抽象的一个球
你可以认为就是到大气层的上限
大气的上限是什么呢
就是霍夫面
大家听没听过这个概念
就是它是离地表向上100km
我们经常讲
就是那个比如说埃隆马斯克嘲笑那个就是杰夫beos和那个谁
那个那个维维机航太空的那个两个两个人
他们说你们那不是太空飞船
因为你还没飞过100km呢
你飞过100km
你才好意思跟我讲
你叫太空飞船对吧
那么那么呢但是云的话呢离我们很近
大概只有几百米上千米对吧
那么你当你移动的时候
你会感觉到语音的巨大的体量感
它是一个体量动力
这两个东西是截然不同的两种表达方法
那其实还有一个东西是什么呢
是fog是雾
但是呢我们今天那个研究了半天
我们觉得这个fog的话呢
我们后面会放在效果里面去讲
因为就是fog它不只是天空的大气现象的一种表达
实际上也是一种非常重要的一种
就是artist控制的效果
所以今天呢我们就把天空和云讲清楚
这个听上去是不是很简单
如果大家画画的话
你会发现画天空画语音都是最好画的
寥寥几笔非常写意对吧
很有感觉
所以你怎么画
但是对于我们的游戏的这个这个这个引擎的开发者来讲的话
这绝对是这个头大的东西
接下来我们先讲这个大气对吧
你可以看到这里面我用的刺客信条确实很漂亮
美得不得了
那传统异能天上的大气真的是随着日出日落对吧
你看到不同的角度
它有各种美轮美奂的颜色变化
那凡事不许怎么样呢
上拟合呀对吧
就像我上次讲材质的时候
我也不管你下面到底是什么
这个物理的实实际是什么
我不懂
太复杂了
但是我可以观察
观察之后呢
我找一个模型去拟合
你对吧
这样不灵风雅了
所以我一直认为这个方法就是这个这个就有点像大世界的这个布灵风
就是咣咣咣给了你一堆公式
你也不用管它
这边就两个参数
一个参数是什么呢
就是你向上看的那个角度到天顶
就是那个zis那个天顶的夹角是多少
但这个一般是零到这个零到派对吧
这个角度还有一个是什么呢
就是你现在看的高度和太阳的夹角是多少对吧
那个它这里面是用了伽马对吧
好
你只要把这两个角度给我诶
我给你查一个表
诶
要把不是查个表
它是算了一个解析解
哎
你就能算出颜色
这边他给出了一个ground truth是什么呀
他真这个老哥真的是拍了一下
然后呢他在游戏中也生成了这个结果
大家看看这感觉是不是还是可以的对吧
简单粗暴爽
如果我现在做过手游的话
假设我这个就是是个无良坑爹的这个手游的话
我觉得这个方法也可以
就就混混也就拉倒了
但是呢它的好处就是非常非常的简单
但是它的坏处是什么呢
它的坏处就是说第一个呢你只能在地表
你没有办法做一个什么效果
就是诶我从太空中飞过来
那个是什么感觉
还有一个就是它所有的参数啊
全部是写死的
你想你这个天空不可能是说永远是那一个一个形式吧
比如说你这个下雨的天
所以呢当我们要真的按3a游戏的标准去做天空的时候
你会发现这个模型就不集中了
好接下来的部分就开始非常的高能了
我觉得我今天很可能我我看看我能不能讲完啊
ok那首先大家要学一个概念
就是这个participating media这个词我都不知道中文怎么叫翻译
它
这个就是像空气中有很多的这种小小的这个东西
然后混合在一起
这个透明罐又不又不透明的
这么一个东西
这里面有很多的例子
那么其实我们看我们的大气层啊
它实际上有两种粒子构成
一种粒子是什么呢
就是各种气体分子对吧
比如说氮气啊
氧气呀对吧
比如说甲烷
二氧化碳
著名的couple dixx型
就是二氧化碳这个单词我学的最深
就是因为我最近老是听什么温室效应对这个词
每天的耳朵就过去了
其实温室效应最最火的应该是甲烷好
这个第二个是什么呢
我们叫气溶胶对吧
astral这个词儿呢是什么意思
就是说诶我的空气中的灰尘或者是形成了一种小的这种气溶胶的分子
那么这些东西的话呢
它也会对空气形成折射和反射对吧
那这些就是我们的形成了我们光在这个厂里面走的
所有的这个就是我的戒指是什么
就是我们周围的大周围不是真空的哦
里面有很多东西
正是因为有这些participating media的话
我们才会产生各种各样复杂的光学现象
那么这个里面就诶这个风尘看着是不是有点吓人了啊
这个方程确实是有点吓人啊
就是说呢他在讲就是说啊这个光啊到底适合这个participant media
是怎么交这个怎么去在一起交互的
那么首先一头一束光射过来
你第一个效果是什么
诶
我中间有我的杂质
对不对
我会把你的光给吸收一点
就吸收的效果对吧
我每往前走了一个单位的距离的话
我有多少的光被吸收
那是不是有一个常数对吧
这个就是吸收的一个常数
一般我们叫做什么那个啊叫sa阿尔法对吧
西格玛阿尔法
那么后呢还有一个是什么呢
就是说哎这个光啊打中我的例子之后
我开始向四面八方开始散射我的能量对吧
那么因为光就像你光打中了一个一个一个气体分子的时候
他就开始无差别的像四周方向去去去散射
那个叫什么叫out scing
就是说我我把你的能量往外散失的部分
这个地方我就有一个就是sigma这个这个这个s skettering
然后呢它会跟着光的方向是有关系的一个方程
还有什么呢
哎我这个气体啊
假设是高温的气体
打个比方
比如说那个火焰对吧
我还带点自发光
或者是我通了个电对吧
比如说我的一个闪电自发光
但其实自发光说实话
当你写方程
你去耍酷的时候
你可以把这个加上去
但是呢呃你不加也没问题
其实我至少you as far
as i know
在游戏中好像很少有人真的这么干
因为前面这这这几项已经是让你头疼肚子疼了
最后一项那是最蛋疼的东西
叫in scattering
什么意思呢
你在空气中的一个小的这个这个一个一个空气的一个介质
实际上你的光是不仅仅是你自己被阳光直接照到了这个行为
还有你周边的那些气体分子都被点亮了
对不对
然后呢他们的他们的出射光就是他们的of scarring
又会打到你的身上
唉我的天
然后呢你要对你还记得我上次在讲那个b r d f材质的时候
我说卡基亚老先生最让我这个这个不满的地方就是他给我的全是积分
而且全是球面上的积分
这个真的是很头疼
但是呢你要算他的那个in sketching
就是来自四面八方的天空的光
来的时候
这就是在球面上的所有的光的贡献做了一个积分
哎呀我的天
这就是一个很复杂的积分
然后呢你把这四种效果合到一起
就形成了一个著名的叫rtf
就是radio transfer function对吧
就是这个这个这个这个叫什么这个辐射传递方程
这个方程呢实际上我在这边写的是一个很简单的一个一倍方程嘛
但实际上呢在三维空间的话呢
它是一个梯度方程
那么那这个t的方程讲起来就比较复杂了
我们就不讲了
那个大家如果在大学里面学过什么拉普拉拉拉斯算子这些东西的时候
就知道我在讲什么
但是说实话我也就是最近这两天我在备课的时候
我把这些东西全复习了一遍
我备课之前我基本上全忘记了
我说啊我的天呐
怎么这么麻烦呢
对吧
我这个待会给大家解释
就是大家别怕
你需要知道这些概念
但是呢你不用记住这些公式
我我保证你绝对不需要记住好
接下来我们继续往下啊
好那么我从眼睛看过去
远处的一个点就是m我
我现在眼睛在p那我看到的这个光的现象到底是由什么东西构成的
这个方程写起来又是各种玄乎对吧
它原则上来讲的话就是从m点
我一次一次一个一个点
我去算它的这个光被吸收的部分
光被散射出去的部分
其他地方散射的光又再进来了
这个时候我其实呢会有两个值
一个值叫什么呢
叫那个transmittance
就是通透度
什么意思
就是说我在m点的看到的东西
比如说它是个蓝色的东西
它大概有多少会保留到我在p点看到的东西
这是一个路径积分的一个结果
还有一个东西是什么呢
叫做它的这个skettering function
就是说你在这个你在你过来的时候
我又叠加了沿途的所有的例子
它无论是从上下左右射过来的光
最后通过他的各种散射
又到我的眼睛去了对吧
那这个这个沿着这个路径的积分的话呢
就是它的scattering part
基本上你你知道了通透度
你知道scanning power
你在那个m那个点
你放个什么东西
我知道它的光场的话
我就大概知道我看到那个m点是什么样子
这个方程呢就是著名的就是这个volume render equation v r e对吧
你说这个呃这个我们的先贤们是不是很厉害
两页p p t两组公式
但实际上大家不要怕
就是这个呢r t f是表示一个梯度
那你对这个梯度的积分啊
就是这个v r e
那不懂积分怎么办
没关系
不用知道了
因为这些东西呢到最后我们全部给你预测到好
待会我们继续往下讲
大家在这一定义里面
只要记住两个概念
就是假设空气中有这个有很多participating media
就是中间有这种啊
不是真空的
有很多这种空气体的这种杂质的时候
你其实有两个很关键的变量
就是当一束光照过了
第一个变量就是说在远处看到一个东西
它有多少能透视到我
就transmitters
就到你能到我的眼睛的部分对吧
那么第二个呢就是说哎你因为光打到这个空气的这个分子里面
你乱七八糟的散射到最后诶
沿着这条光路方向给我的眼睛有多少能量
that's it
就这样很简单好
那我们继续研究我们的大气的真实的物理学啊
这里面就很高能了
这个真实的大气物理学啊
它实际上有两个主要的参与者
第一个是什么太阳
太阳是一切的贡献者对吧
太阳的是一束光射到地球上
大家注意啊
太阳光你看到的是什么
是白色的对吧
但事实上呢太阳光是有大量的不同波长的光组成的
只是我们的人眼经过亿万年的进化
我们把这个波长的组合定义成白色
仅此而已对吧
实际上它的波长很多
各种波长
第二个是什么呢
就是刚才我提到就是大气中有两类东西
一类是气体分子对吧
它的尺寸呢是小于这些波长的
一般的小于这些波长
还有一类是什么呢
是这个就是气溶胶分子
它一般是接近于这些光的波长的
那么好了
它们的性质就完全不一样了
那这里面给大家介绍两种完全不同的散射模型啊
一个呢叫做really scattering
这个翻译成中文叫瑞利散射
好像叫瑞利散是吧
这个名字取的好像个女生的名字
但实际上我也不知道这个名字为什么这么叫
可能是个发明酒的人的
那么的话呢它的特点是什么呢
就是当这个空气中的介质啊
它尺寸远小于光的波长的时候
那么这个光啊就几乎会在四面八方几乎均匀的散射
不太具有方向性
其实还是有一定方向性
但是我会具体的讲
但是它有个特点是说对于越短的波长
它散射的越厉害
对于越长的波长
它散射的越越越
那个就是越小
什么哪些波长短
蓝光紫光对吧
紫外线
紫外线嘛
对不对
那么哪个波长长呢
那可能就是这个比如说红光这些东西
那么还有一类散射是什么呢
叫密散射
密散射这个哎呀真的叫叫米氏散射对吧好吧
就我们叫它米式散射
我真的不太记得他中文名叫什么了
然后呢这个它的特点是什么呢
它是由气溶胶
就是它的它的尺寸是接近或者大于那个波长的时候诶
它就有一定的方向性对吧
它就是你沿着光的方向一般会略强一点
但是它有一个区别是什么呢
就是说它呢对波长不敏感
管你什么波长
我我都是一视同仁
这就非常有意思了
我们先讲这个瑞利散射
锐意散射
这边是它的一个就比较假设光啊
沿着这个大家看左边那个图啊
右边这个图当光沿着方向过来的时候
它其实散射的这个分布啊
像一个什么
大家看像一个花生
对不对对吧
两头稍微大一点
中间稍微扁一点
这也符合它的光学原理嘛
那么还有一点是什么呢
你会发现短波长蓝光的它的辐射度会高很多
对不对
但是呢这个长波上红光它的反射度就比较低
这里面就引入了一个大名鼎鼎的这个这个方程
这个方程呢叫做这个fafunction
什么意思
就是说这就是我我特别想讲啊
就是这个呃这个数学家是很了不起的一个物种
就是你看到这个公式铺天盖地的很复杂对吧
大家不要怕
实际上它就两个部分
第一个部分呢是它的就是叫face function
就是它的几何形状
这个几何形状你说它复杂吗
其实很简单
就是一加cos theta
大家学过那个就是高中的代数
你把cos c它的平方加上个一
你得到的就是这个腰果的形状
大家仔细画一下就知道了
就是极坐标计算
所以我觉得这个方方程啊在我看来就是还你看着它很高端
但其实还是个拟合对吧
他就骇客了一下
说我大概就这样
但这里面的话呢它引入了几个很有意思的参数
第一个它有一个number number
是什么光的波长
它这里面你会发现就是一除以number的四次方
意味着就是当光的波长越短的时候
它这个散射的强度是不是越高对吧
第二个呢就是说它这个光啊
它这个是受制于什么呢
里面有个变量叫做h就是你会发现这个方程里面有三个变量
一个是number one
我讲的是波长sa就是你跟它这个光的之间这个夹角
这个夹角的话呢
它是ice tate
就是它在旋转的时候是不变的好
但是呢h是很有意思的一个变量
大家一定要记住海拔高度
大家想想看大气的密度是什么变化
是不是在海拔为零的时候
浓度最大
越往上它是有一个接近于线性的对吧
越来越稀疏
但这个到底是线性还是非线性就不重要
重要的
因为搞同学的人
我就还一样
我们就假设这个线性就是
那么我们会认为你跟空气的密度在地平线上的这个区别到底是多少
我们呢就那个大案
就是说一个标准单位体系里面的空气的密度
和你在以真实的海拔高度的密度的变化
这样的话我们现在做什么
比如说你从珠峰上开一架飞机降落到那个海平面上的时候
你看那个效果其实在里面你就会发生这个变化
所以呢这个方程你去理解它
就是所有左边那么长的一个东西
他到最后你会发现
对于任何一个这个给定的这个海拔高度和空气密度来说
它就是一个常数
而真正沿着方向在变化的就是那个叫fafunction
那是一个方向
那个方程非常的简单
它实际上只跟一个角有关系对吧
那么有了这个方程
我们去理解一个很有意思的光学现象
就是为什么天空是蓝的
你看硕图心学的人
他就是很有意思
就是我们真的是个博物学家
就是你会发现这很简单
就是当太阳直射的时候对吧
大量的蓝光它会呢在大气层里被散射开来
然后呢经过多次散射进入眼睛
红光的是直接照在地上的
但你你不会抬头直看太阳
你往旁边看天空的时候
就天空来回bounce的
因为really散射的时候
那个蓝光的你们来回bs技能眼睛
那为什么你到傍晚的时候天空是红的呢
因为那个他很斜
很多蓝光它照到在大气层边缘
直接往大气层外面去散射了
所以呢天空中蓝色的部分越来越少
反而红色的部分就多了对吧
但这里面和外面还有一个吸收线
也会加剧这个红色
待会儿再讲怎么样完美的解决了天空为什么是蓝的对吧
这个这可是这个怎么说呢
难倒了我们人类物理学家上千年的一个问题啊
好那么密散射的话呢跟它不一样
历史你看啊
这是我们看出来密散射的这个方程
这个方程是这个形状
我觉得真的是很神奇啊
我觉得是一只大带鱼还是大章鱼
我也不知道
反正就是这样一个很奇怪的一个形状
但是呢这个问题难不倒我们的数学家
数学家
凡事不许上礼盒对吧
你看这个方程呢就比较复杂了
它其实啊左边那一夸啦
也是跟你的高度
海拔高度跟你的空气的密度有关系
ok我把你全部变成一个常数
不用管它
然后呢我要模拟那个形状
它呢你可以看到它一堆cos c它的变化
但这里面它引入了一个非常有意思的我
我叫做gre parameter
叫g这个g很有意思
就是说当g等于零的时候
你会发现啊
他这边的这个face function会退化成跟瑞利散射一模一样的
一个一个一个一个就是花生豆的形状不会这么复杂
但是呢当你的g大于一的时候
它就会越来越趋近这边的形状
但是g呢其实是可以小于零的
呃大于零啊
当g小于零的时候呢
它表示的是说往往那个光线的相就是相反的方向反射的越多
但是一般来讲我们在用的时候
基都是大于零的
这里面只跟大家讲一个数学的东西
这个东西呢大家不要怕
因为它实际上就是一个拟合方程对吧
它的计算也并不复杂
那么这个g呢我们一般会开放给我们的artist去调整
这个月是原则上来讲的话
就是不同尺寸的particle
它的记忆会一直有变化好这就是我们的整个一个数学体系对吧
那这个那个这个密反密的散射呢
其实也是我们最重要的一个效果
比如说吧大家看到的雾雾是空气中的小水珠嘛
那么它其实就是个气溶胶
那你看到雾为什么是白色的
这里面白色的太阳光照下来
所有的波长无差别的散射
最后你看到就是白茫茫的雾对吧
所以务实很多时候是没有颜色的
那么像那个我们看到的那个傍晚的日运的话
也是因为逆闪是因为它是带有方向性的
所以说你看到这个光就差汇集到你的眼睛去了
所以在那个太阳旁边
你会看到那个how halo是光晕的
这个现象也是个点
包括你在雨天雾天看到那个路灯也会看到这个效果
也就是密散射好
这个讲起来是不是很复杂
是的很复杂
因为你如果想做一个高水平的游戏引擎的话
这都是你必须要解决的问题
好了呀
这个就很麻烦了呀
那么还有一个很重要的现象是什么呢
叫做光的吸收
能量被吸收
我们刚才讲了
刚才我们一直讲散射对吧
但其实还有个吸收吸收呢
这里面就讲一些物理学有意思有意思的原理呢
比如说我们大气中的臭氧和甲烷
它们呢都是吸收长波的高手
那么它可以吸收这个这个红红色的光
所以呢比如说像那个就是那个海王星
为什么看起来是蓝色的
就是因为它表面有很多甲烷
所以当太阳光照过去的时候
它的红色都被吸收走了
所以我就剩下蓝色
你能看见了
那么其实这个臭氧很有意思
我自己那天我们在我们在做备课的时候
还在说
诶
我记得那个臭氧是吸收紫外线的吗
其实你看v k p d啊
他也说它吸收了个uv嘛
就是那个紫外线
但是呢我觉得可能是在可可进化波段
它吸收的是那个红色多一点
但是在不可见的波段的话
它有另外一种形式
那这个就更复杂了
我们今天不展开
但是呢当我们去计算大气的现象的时候
我们确实要考虑吸收效应
但是呢在这里面我们要做个假设
什么假设呢
就是当我给出一个大气的模型的时候
我会认为臭氧和甲烷是均匀的分布在这个这个这个大气层里面
实际上不是对吧
臭氧层是在天上的
但是呢我们算的时候耍流氓
我们就把它均匀算
因为这个这个模型实在太复杂了
好好了
这就是我们的整个大戏的物理模型
大家感觉怎么样
是不是基本上要爆炸了对吧
觉得这个这个怎么可能解呢
这个确实很难解
而且这里面有很多的两重积分在一个地方
那么这里面再讲一个很著名的概念呢
就是说叫single skettering和multiscare
叫单次的这个散射和多次散射
其实它通原理上解释是非常的简单
就是说当我眼睛看到一个远处的一个点
我看到的所有光线是沿我的视线看到的
所有的大气粒子被太阳光照亮
然后呢散射到我这个方向的这个点的能量的加在一起就是家和拉倒
这其实不是价格
它就远处的那个点的能量还要被中间就是就刚才讲的transmitters
就是还要通过一个通透度进行这个积分到我的眼睛的结果
这就是单词的scattery
这件事情是不是已经很复杂了
对不对
但是实际上呢我们去看大气现象
它绝对没这么简单
为什么在这些沿途的这些粒子空间的话
我们还有很多其他的例子
他们从各种角度去照我的眼睛对吧
比如说上面的一个一个一个一个例子
他虽然不在我的视线上
对哦它不对
它是它
它虽然不在线
但是它可以照亮我路径上的一个一个点
那个点沿着我这个方向又一个能量的这个反射
这是什么呢
我们叫做multi scattering
实际上真正做大气现象的话
最让人难受的
最让人头疼的就是这个东西
你想做一个美丽的天空
不好意思
你没有
这个效果是不息的
大家看这张图
左边这张图的话就是只有single casketchy
你看这个天空样子
我觉得还是蛮好看的对吧
还可以
你可以看到就是太阳在地平线以下天上出现了那种诶有点这种暖色调
然后再向那个冷色调的蓝色慢慢过渡
但是你会发现山的背面是一片死黑
为什么呢
single scattering的话
它基本上那个地方是没有光的
但是真实的大气是怎么回事
如果大气中有很多的例子的话
这些在你头顶上的这些空气也会被点亮
然后他光会散射开来
然后呢又再把你面前的这些这个山背后的空气又给点亮了
所以你会发现虽然阳光照不到伤背面
但伤背面其实是有亮度的对吧
这个但这个大家注意啊
这个跟我们讲的那个gi不是一个道理
因为积压指的是说我背后假设有个山的另外一面
它被照亮了
这个这个山的背面的光也反射过了
但是gi但是这个multiscattering指的是他是他没有清晰的面
他是无时无无刻不在的这种连续的
就叫participate media
就是就是这个怎么比方呢
就是充满空间的空气
就像以前那个经典物理学家讲
就是充满空间的以太阳
每个以太分以太那个原子都在这里面干了很多的这个复杂的事情
然后你一般把他所有的行为积存放在一起
这个时候你才能产生我们想要的这样的一个光学效果
这件事情听上去真的是很蛋疼
但实际上如果你在做今天这个时代的3a游戏的话
这是我们必须要解决和面对的问题
好那这个问题怎么办
那前面我首先给大家介绍一个非常著名的一个
一个也是大名鼎鼎的算法
你看只要著名的算法都叫marching
这叫remarching
这个像这个算法呢其实非常的简单
就是沿着一条视线
我把沿途的效果一步一步叫marshine
就是走路嘛一步一步的积分起来
那么比如说刚才我们讲的那个single skettering
就是单次散射的结果的话
是不是我沿着我的视线的方向均匀的踩很多的点
然后呢我算太阳照到这个点上
这个离子的强度是多少
和它的方向
我根据他的scattering就散射方程
你把我把你的me啊
really啊
方程先算一遍
我现在算出说你头像我的这个光度是多少
然后我沿路就这样积分下去
我是不是就可以算出来我的single sky那里面讲的还少了一个细节
就是远处的还要经过一次transmitters
就是说它是有通透度的计算的
但这个不展开了
它的核心思想
就是说我就沿着一条射线直直接积分下去
实际上我们在算所有的大气效果的话
用的都是这个思路
嗯啊天呐
已经一个小时40分钟了
我怀疑我今天要奔着两个半小时去了
这个ok反正我看到同学们很希望我脱单
那今天我们到时候看上b站视频的时候
我们看能不能切成两段
因为否则这个视频就太长了
好那么你有了这样一个remarching这样的一个数学工具的时候呢
其实我们就可以用我们的最著名的方法
我记得在上节课
上节课我们反复强调的什么叫计算复杂
用空间来算对吧
就叫做就是用空间换时间
我们可不可以把这些复杂的计算预先算好
然后呢把它存在一个表上
然后呢到到渲染的时候
我只是根据我现在视线的方向
太阳的角度
我查一个角就可以查得到这个想法
是不是很直接
对不对
那刚才我讲的就是你大气中的光学现象
其实只有两个最重要的部分
大家还记得吗
第一个部分叫做transmitters
通透度对吧
也就是说我现在看到远处离我那么远的东西
我大概能看到你的30%还是70%
还是99%
对不对
这就是通透度
还有一个是什么呢
就是scattering
来我这边的散射度是多少
那我们先算通透度怎么算
其实这里面我觉得我们要引入一个很著名的模型了
叫做pre computer atmosphere
atatmospa
这个scattering就这个方法是非常非常经典的
这个是应该是brunton那个老先生在2000
不是老先生
这个人可能很年轻啊
大概2006年左右做了一个算法吧
就是说他想了一个办法
就是我把空间中的任何就是地表
地球表面的任何一个点
我算它的海拔高度
在这个海拔高度呢
我存两个值
一个值就是你的视线和天顶之间的那个夹角
就是那个theta对吧
我我用你的扩散theta进行参数化的表达
还有一个是什么呢
就是说诶我现在跟海拔高度的区别
然后呢你从这个点往大气层去看
因为我现在只能算通透度嘛
所以说我不需要知道太阳在哪里
我只需要知道就是这个通透在哪里
那你从这个点出发
一路走到大气层的边界
一般我们设定为就是以地球中心
假如地球是6440米的半径的话
那应该是在6540米的那个千米的那个地方啊
不算6440千米的那个半径的话
那么它应该在6540km的那个地方
就是1百米100km的后封面的那个地方
那么我这根线跟它的交角
就是我看到那个它的镜头
你应该看到的是通透是多少
这个是有点意思吧
就是比如太空中有个东西的话
假设没有太阳
我们可以看到那个太空中的星星
说明什么
虽然大气层很厚
有100km
但是它是什么
它还是通透的
这个大家能理解吗
那么好
我其实呢就用这么一个简单的方法
我就可以把整个大气层的通透的这个方程就表达出来了
那么好了
但这个时候呢我假设在远处
我有一座山
或者有一个光
有一个粒子的发射的光到底有多少能透到我的眼前
就在这张图中的话
你可以看到我们设置两个点
一个是x v就是你眼睛所在的位置
还有一个点是什么呢
是叫xm
就是你中间有一个物质点对吧
middle的那个点不一定是mid
就是中间那个点
然后呢你会发现啊
实际上你有这个表
你可以去查
在这个从xv就是你眼睛那个位置到大气层边界的这个通透度
把它呢做分母
它的分子是什么呢
就是从那个m点沿着同样的一条线到大气层边界的通透度是多少
然后呢你把这两个tto这样一个分子
一个分母一除诶
你就能得到他的通透度
这里的具体的数学推导我不展开了
但这个方法真的是非常巧妙的
就是说他用了一个简单的二维的方程
把一个四维的值就给算出来了
因为一个简单的除法
这个具体的同学们有兴趣可以推导一下对吧
但但是作为作为我当年就是我基本上知道这个东西了
我觉得太牛逼了
然后就大胆的去用了
就假设它永远是对的
对吧好
那么这个时候我有了通透度之后
接下来我就可以算什么呢
我就可以算他的
大家刚才特别特别蛋疼的single scattering
就是你那个single scattering呢
就是单次散射确实很复杂
但是呢你有了通透度
你就沿着那个那个刚才给的那个方程啊
你就一路一小步一小步积分
你是一定能算出来的
它真正的难点不在于计算说从a点到b点的这个这个
这个这个散射的强度的难度
而在于是说我对于整个地球上这么大的一个就是3d的空间
我在各种各样的可能的视角
我在各种各样可能的太阳的方向
我怎么去对大家进行表达
这件事情是很复杂
那这里面的话呢
我认为最重要的一个思想就是一个参数化的思想
什么意思
就是说我还是在地球表面离海拔高度选择一个爱h高度的地方
我呢朝一个方向去看
那这样的话呢我可以得到一个叫天顶角对吧
我的天顶角一个参数化的表达
然后呢这个我会一路这条射线会达到大气层的边界
所以那个我不需要知道我的终点在哪
我我我因为是个球嘛
所以我永远知道那个大型的边界离我多远
只要我知道我的角度还有一个什么呢
太阳现在挂的角度
注意啊
这个时候你看的这个角度和太阳卦的角度和天津的方向
它是个什么角
它不是个平面的角
它是个立体角
所以这里面我们就得到了三个角度量
第一个是太阳到天津的角度
大家想太阳到中午的时候
是不是离听点越来越近对吧
那个cos的那个那个就是那个那个词儿
我叫n n格玛
还叫什么
whatever
就是它等于一
对不对
但是它太阳越靠近那个地平线以下的时候
它那个值就趋近于零了
对吧
好
你呢看也是呀
你看天空看看天顶有个角度
然后呢看见旁边也有一个角度
那好那这个角度你也给算出来好
我们把天顶的轴线确定了
确定的话
那这个时候第三个量是什么呢
是我的视线和太阳之间的这个夹角
在这里面是用fi去表达了
你会发现如果我们这是一个完美的球形的话
所以他在任何一个点上
他的天顶方向就是它的那个法线方向对吧
那你无论怎么转
太阳和你的相对位置怎么转
只要这个球上的大气层
它是虹膜基尼的虹膜镜子
就是就是说它的各项同志的吧
它其实不不是红的
就是各项各个方向
假设是等等价的变化的话
实际上我只需要去存这三个角度的信息
我就能表达所有的从我现在这样看过去
看到太空的点的这样的一个沿途的散射值
这个这个东西大家回去可以推一下
其实非常的简单
那么我再沿着高度进行一个采样
我就一路的这样去采
然后用这样的一个简单的方法
我们呢就可以得到一个四维表
对这个里面是四维表吧
这个就比较复杂
但是呢感谢现在硬件我们有什么呢
有texture ray
大家还记得我们有texture re对吧
其实这里面不应该应该用3d texture
为什么呢
我沿着他现在他的package的时候
沿着海拔高度依次进行采样
那么呢比如说我1百米踩一个
2百米踩一个
3百米踩一个
但是我人可能是在175米
这个时候我可能就在1百米2百米之间去采这个人
因为这个信号全是低频的
所以差值是没有问题的
然后呢我在x轴的话
我把这个天顶角
我把这个我们和太阳的角度pk在一起对吧
反正这里面这个这是一个规划的一个细节
但这个大词你看你能明白
实际上我前面通过各种复杂的计算
我实际上是把这个世界上的光啊
如果只有一次scattering
就一次散射的话
我全部就存下来了对吧
用remix的方法
那我有了这个通透度的分布图
就是大气的这种就是光过来的这个通透性的transmitters的这个图
我又有了这个一次散射的图
我把一次散射所有的空气的点都会被散射的点照亮
对不对
我用这个照亮的点
再通过通透度再做一次积分
是不是能得到就是二次散射的图
那么我可以做二次
三次
四次五次
其实理论上你可以做无穷次
但一般来讲我们做3~4次基本上就够用了
那这个时候我们是不是就可以得到一个叫multi sketching的这个look up table
它的结构啊其实和这个表是一模一样的
因为这是一个完美的对这个就是这种光学现象的一个参数化表达
但是呢只是你ma sketching的话呢
就是你会两张图看上的区别是什么
就是你每加一次这个那个multsketching
它这个图会看上去亮那么一点点
但是到后面这种变化你基本上已经注意不到了
所以这就是很著名的这个computed atmosphere的这个sketching
算法的核心思想
它本质上就是说我用预计算的方法
预计算是用什么方法
是用remarching的方法去把这种大气里面的这种散射现象
通透to这个现象全部变成了表格
然后呢一路给你算好
这样的话在我绘制的每一个点的时候
我就可以用这个效果嗯
那么其实呢这个方法你看上去很复杂
但是呢当你把所有的一计算全部做完之后
那你在run time
你去用它的时候
那就真的是非常简单
而且的话它真的能够模拟日落日出的效果
这这几个游戏都是大作游戏啊
比如像非法对吧
像那个就是极品飞车
这都是呃
这这边paper的话呢
就是戴斯的做的这个东西
就是大家可以看到就是这基本上已经达到了state of 2的效果
就是现在很前沿的一个效果
非常的漂亮
那么那么一计算呢
实际上你一个关卡如果这些参数不动的话
就比如说你大气的参数不动的话
你太阳动
你人动
你一会儿坐飞机从地面到就从地表起飞到天空中都没有问题
他这个确实做的非常的强大
那么当然这里面有个细节我就没有去讲
就是说呃远处我不仅看到天空的颜色
实际上远处一个物体我要加物效
其实这个方法呢在这里面有一个小的细节
就是在这里面就是说它实际上是那个我先算
我当前看到大气层的边缘的时候
注射的这个这个这个sky就散射的这个这个能量
然后呢从你那个远处的物体的物理点
你散失的能量
然后呢你的能量又要被那个就是那个transpency的这个能量被减弱
这两个的一个差值就可以算出来
说我的远处的山他接受了多少的天光
到我的眼里面
这个讲起来就比较复杂了
我就不展开了
但是你会发现就在远处的时候
比如说天假设是蓝蓝的
你看远处那个山
它也会变得有点越来越蓝
而不是一个简单的只是变暗
其实就是这个效果
那么用这个方法的话呢
也能够完美地实现这个方实现这个效果
那么所以呢这个方法其实真的是非常经典的
就是那个brunton这个方法
我认为是非常经典的一个算法
那么它有没有问题
其实呢呃它还是有很多的问题的
第一个呢就是它的计算是非常的费的
就是说你刚才可以看到就是我要做很我对每一个思维的表
我都要做一次remarching对吧
然后呢就是说呃我们在比如说打个比方
比如说我们在移动端的这个手机上
这个计算就很蛋疼
现在我在pc上
我有computer shader
我可以算还可以
但是也是需要大概比如说呃几毫秒吧
甚至有可能到一秒
但是呢我们可以把它分散到很多
真逐渐松的
比如关卡加载时我就算一下
但是的话呢当artist的说
唉你把这个大气算好了
我不干
为什么呢
比如说我要表达一个效果
是刚才还是蓝天白云
突然开始要下雨了
那下雨的空气中有很多小水珠对吧
然后呢这个大气的折射和散射就会发生变化
那个时候你会觉得有点雾蒙的感觉
这种这个两个效果呢之间是要均匀的过渡的
每一帧都要插值的
那这个时候你就很麻烦了
因为你就相当于说每一帧你都要再把刚才那个表再算一遍
刚才那个算表也很麻烦对吧
你怎么算呢
包括我们的artist在会在在编辑这个环境的时候
我们要经常调这个数值
这个方法他也会很麻烦
你动不了
另外一个的话呢
在run time的时候
虽然尼德已经是用空间换时间了
但是大家仔细去推演一下
你会发现其实他要做很多次的高维表的差值
而且高维表的插曲呢是非常费的
就是说啊
因为比如说我我硬生生的把一个思维数据pin到三维的数据的时候
其实我很多interpolation需要我手动去做的
比如说我要取一个值的时候
我要在四个点取值
然后再自己做差值
我要几次的
而且刚才给大家讲的就这么大的texture啊
这个泰勒不大了
但是我的memory会降不来降不去
然后作为一大堆的数学运算
所以呢它其实很复杂
所以这里面的话呢这也是我们104课程的一个精神嘛
就是说我们会跟大家讲一些点一些非常前沿的一个方法
这里面的话呢我们要浓重的去讲一下
就是今天那个在游戏行业大家在用的一个方法
就是也许我们可以用更简单的方法
但是呢是能解决这个问题
这个方法实际上在啊今天的ue里面就用了这个方法
就是它是强调的就是如何叫a scalable
and这个这个就是production ready的这个sky and at the field的一个rendering technique
这个方法我不展开
不讲的太复杂了
跟他讲一个他几个很有意思的一个思想
这个思想我觉得他们大家特别需要学习
他先做了一个非常非常大胆的假设
他说啊你在空气中最麻烦的是什么呢
算这个散射嘛对吧
就msketching就是一次二次三次散射
但是他说散射这件事情特别的低频
对空气中的一个分子
你来自四面八方散射
你可以近似认为它就是在各项分布是同样的
这个假设是不是很大的
对不对
但是这个大胆假设有一个很牛逼的属性是什么呢
就是说如果你来自于四面八方的光的是均匀的
那实际上这些光入射到你的点上
你再反射回来的话
是不是就是一个百分比的衰减对吧
也就是说光是四面方向均匀的进了
然后呢你不管用什么方程散射
你就算是个什么情况
你你最后散射的各个方向都是均匀的
那实际上你就是个能量衰减的问题对吧
也就是大气分子被加热了
然后呢我们散射出了比损失了30%的能量
所以呢你只要算出一次到两次的这样的一个散射
你就可以算出一个百分比
然后你会发现再往上的话
每次都是百分比的一个级数
这个级数就意味着什么
意味着说我可以用一个最简单的高中数学知识
我就可以算出他无数次方次的时候
就是multiscaring的这样的一个贡献度
你想这个方法是不是很流氓
但这个方法真的就就work了
他就这么干了
所以就不用像我们那么麻烦的
就是每一次算它的反射散射的时候
我们都要全部再做一次路径积分
搞得一塌糊涂
对就他就他就没有这个事儿了
那么第二件事情是什么呢
刚才那个卢卡表不是很麻烦吗
思维嘛对吧
他都在想说哎呀你既然这个世界要动态
我就省一点事嘛
就比如说第一个我假设你的位置就不变了
你假设我每一帧都算
那你的高度
你我我对每个海拔高度去采样
对我有什么意义呢
没义对吧
那我就把你们的这个h这个维度给它干掉了对吧
第二个就是说太阳我每一帧都算你太阳在每一帧的时候
它的位置不是固定的吗
对不对
好
那我把那个太阳那个维度就干掉了
最后他就用一个非常简单的方法
就是说诶我一个是天顶角
一个是360度环角
我就把你这个天空的这个multsketching的反射就全部给你算完了
这个真的是非常的了不起
但这里面这个看到图应该是sk jsk scarring
那哦这个这里面这已经是它的结果了
这个时候他还又算了一个东西
它是这样的
他就说ok我大气中的这种沿着路径的这种透明度的积分
对不对
那我就一路算过去吧
我就一路做过3d texture
根据距离的远近
这个时候呢诶我又形成了一个积分
这样的话我整个天空的modescaring所有效果
这个图前面那个图有点错误
前面那个图应该只有single single sketching
实际上啊它实际上那个表里面可以有msketching加上那个无效的效果
所以这个想法其实非常的简单
但是的话呢它就是符合我们前面讲的那个迪士尼精神
就是它并不是物理上完全正确的一个方法
但是呢他对于我们的艺术家来讲是非常非常友好的
而且这件事情还有一个好处是什么呢
就是它能够让我们的艺术家可以创造各种各样的奇怪的星球
打个比方
比如说我天上有两个太阳对吧
不是一个太阳
一个月亮都在照我
我看过太阳
太阳那边有日晕
看月亮
月亮那边也有月运
那这样的效果怎么办
或者这个地方的气体的效果是一直在变的
就是刚才我讲的这个
比如说一会儿下雨
一会儿起雾
一会儿怎么样
他都能表达
所以这里面给大家看一下它的效果
这个是一个现在的慢慢慢慢的越来越多的公司在在用的一个方法
那么它的好处就是在硬件上
实际上的话是非常的高效
而且呢跟那个brono那个方法呢
我个人觉得差别没有特别大
但是他自己也讲了
在有些情况下
就是比如说那个空气中的那个就是散射度过高的情况下
比如说就是特别特别浓的这种大气的情况下
它的误差会有点大
甚至会出现色偏
那么好给大家看一下它的效果
大家可以发现就是说它能够表达很多动态的效果
这是一个很a脸的星球
大家看到天上飘的都不知道什么什么星体
因为我们是什么
我们是做游戏引擎
游戏引擎是干什么的
就是我们在完全的创造一个想象中的世界
所以呃earth虽然是我们的母亲
但是我们要从earth上学的一些算法
让它能表达各种各样就是beyond earth的东西
所以我个人的话是非常喜欢这个算法的
我觉得我个人觉得这个方法是非常有潜力
所以这个呢也是目前比较前沿的一个做大气的一个方法
同学们如果感兴趣的话
我觉得作为你的毕设大作业是一个非常好的一个选择
就是难度其实并不像大家想象的那么大
而且有大量的代码可以去下载
但是你把这个东西真的吃透的话
你会发现非常的有意思
好好的
那我们基本上想到这一趴呢
我们就把这个天空讲完了
我已经讲了快两个小时了
我后面这把会讲的比较快了
其实确实要抓紧时间了
那么接下来呢就是那个云语音呢
这个东西呢实际上是非常了不起的
其实人类对语音的观察是几百年前的最开关
因为最早我们要关注天气嘛
对气象学家最早意识的语音是有三种类型的
一种是什么呢
一种是层云
就是那个status
就是一层的很很薄的一层云
然后呢就是那个umulus
就是说层积雨越来越厚对吧
还有一种鱼是什么呢
叫serious
就是说卷云就是小小像卷羊毛样的
那么其实你会发现就是说我们在做这个图形学的时候
真的你不小心
你还得学很多气象学的知识
其实大气中的云啊
它基本上就这三种的东西在组合在不同高度对吧
在低空的时候
你看到的就是层云和积云
然后呢到中空的时候呢
就是这个这个就是大概在几千米的时候
你看到叫高空的残余和高空的机云
然后呢再往上的话就是高空的这种卷的层云和卷的这个基因
就这些东西
那么这个东西看起来很简单
怎么去表达它
这里面的话呢我给大家去讲这个最经典的方法
最简单的方法是什么呢
就是用mash硬生生的表达这个方法
大家不要笑啊
这其实早年真的有人这么干过
但这个可能更偏学术一点
就是artist
你去放几个大物体书
我大概想要这种形状的云
然后呢他用各种各样的noise啊
腐蚀算法呀
哎最后真的给你形成了一个语音的这样一个集合
但这个方法呢实话实说就是几乎基本上没有人去用它
我们在过去的十几年甚至更早的时候
大家怎么做鱼大家我现在有很多同学能想到很简单
我们用大量的插片
半透明的插片
各种阿尔法的混合对吧
我们就能形成这样的云的效果
大家现在如果打开10年前的那些网游啊
更早的游戏的时候
你会发现那些语音就基本上这种方法去做的
看着嘛像个天上飘的巨大的棉花糖
然后呢你觉得他不是云吧
他也是项羽
但是你看着总是那么差那么点意思
对不对
那么既然我们要立志做这个3a游戏引擎的话
那肯定这个方法是不行的
那所以呢现在在主流的游戏中
最常用的语音的表达方式呢是用一个就是volumetric
cloud modeling的方法
诶你看这里面又来了warning magic对吧
刚才我在讲地形的时候
我就吐血的推荐说
我们要理解一下什么叫用那个vocal的方式
就是volumetric
就是用体积的每一个vocal的方式去表达空间
表达形体
你在做云的时候
你不理解这个方法
不好意思
你就真的做不了了
ok好那这个方法的好处是什么呢
就是它是全动态的
全是在runtime用用那个cpu生成的
它那个云可以表现出很多的变化
因为呃它的形态也很多变
而且还可以还可以云可以飘移各种各样的效果
但是它的唯一的唯一的问题是什么呢
这个算法非常的复杂
而且呢还很expensive
就是语音要做不好的话
会把整个游戏的效效效率下降非常非常多
但是呢架不住啊
就现在游戏对效果要求越来越高兴
大家基本上都在用这个方法去做一些3a级的游戏好
那这里呢因为时间的关系啊
所以说我不会讲的特别的细
但是给大家讲一些他最基本的一个思想就好了
那么首先的话呢就是说他用一个叫visa texture
videtexture
有两个部分构成
第一个部分呢就是说诶我随机的这个语音的分布在空空间的分布
第二个呢它的the texture channel里面存了一个0~1之间的值
其实代表的是语音的厚度
刚才我不是讲了那个陈云对吧
然后那个就是陈云和积云之间的混合物
叫那个street umulus对吧
然后我们在这umulus就是我们的基因
那好就是0~1的值
诶我的云的厚度越来越不一样
然后你会发现就是说到那个值调整的时候
同样是那个空间上那个云
你会发现它的厚度是越来越厚了
对不对
所以一张visa texture
这个texture很有用啊
比如说啊我们要想这个云飘起来怎么办
我们就把这个via texture进行平移
这个语音是不是在天上就飘起来了
对不对
如果让这个语音有些变化的时候
我是不是可以对那个texture进行一些扰动
进行一些各种各样的变化
这个语音也就发生了变化了
所以这件事情是非常有意思的
就是这是我们的magic好好
这里面我要给大家介绍两个大名鼎鼎的
就是noise function
我相信很多同学在做别的同学都听说过
就是噪音
噪音是我们很讨厌的东西
对不对
但是呢在其实在信号处理
在这个图形学中
噪音是我们的好伙伴
那这里面有两个著名的方程
一个叫noise
那个pretty noise
就是那个哎中文不知道怎么说了
反正叫pinnoise
然后呢他是一个非常了不起的一个方法
就是哎呀这个不展开讲了
其实关于poynurse
我觉得讲个20分钟都可以的
就真的很很聪明很聪明
就是用了一个多项式的时间
就能形成这样一个像棉花絮的这样的一个效果对吧
那么那个另外一个很著名的叫word noise
warning noise呢
它它的近亲是什么呢
就是我们叫做玩i话
就是空间玩any分割什么意思
就是说我给你很多点
我把我在空间把它分割成一个个以它那个点为最近距离的一个cl
这个东西是个什么东西啊
大家如果用电子显微镜啊
用显微镜观察那个很多的生物现象
比如说以细胞核为中心
它形成的细胞壁啊
它就是一个玩让你划分
所以very noise呢
你把它反过来看
它现在形成很多那种泡泡絮的感觉
所以pretty noise
你会觉得像那种棉花丝的感觉
但是呢very noise
它生成的是一个絮状的那种感觉
所以这两个noise方程是我们最常用的两个方程
当然还有其他的方程了
我们今天不展开
你有了这些
为什么这个地方我需要noise function的
因为你刚才不是要声称云吗
你给了我一张texture
我一开始啊给你生成的云啊
其实是很无聊的
他就是诶这张图好像给错
哦对了
它是个柱状的一个一个图
这个看上去不像是云
是天上飘了很多白木头
对不对
那我对这个这个形体用各种各样的noise进行腐蚀
这个里面有一大堆的加减乘除的太可
今天因为时间关系
我就不展开
因为我光讲大家就会觉得很抽象
简单来讲的话
就是说我用高频给他用
先用低频用各种层次的lose noise对它进行
把一些地方给它咬掉
然后呢我再用高频把它一些细节加上很多的细节
这个时候你就能形成一个很像语音的效果
这个效果其实呢从那个刚才我讲
从数学上讲的话
它可以模拟一个近似分型的效果
因为我不可能在run time每一帧去算个分型嘛
所以说我们用了这些大量的noise方程
让你形成了你想要的棉花絮的效果
这个算法其实真的不难
大家如果有兴趣的话
可以自己去写一写
那么但是非常好玩
就是这真的就是shader
the hack
就是你的shader
你改行代码里面有很多很奇怪的magic number
你一动诶
那个云的形态就会发生很多的变化
那么好
你有了这样的一个语音之后
你怎么去渲染它
这个地方是一个比较高能的部分
今天我不展开
但是呢这个云啊他不会真的形成一个面片给你
因为你想那个云的面表面都是那种zz的东西对吧
那那那上百万上千万的面都会生成
那根本画不出来
这个时候就要请出我们著名的叫remarching的算法
就是当我从眼睛看上去天空的任何一个位置
我就往上打
我就打
看看我能不能打到你生成的那个体积
云那么好
这个时候呢就有细节
就是我们会假设所有的语音是在某个特定高度
所以我根据我的相机视角
我第一步尽可能打的离云近一点
但是呢我接下来的步长也比较大
可能是50米
1百米
我就往前走
但是我一旦hit到第一个云的时候
诶我之后就开始耍流氓了
我把它步骤就变得非常小
比如10米1步或者是20米1步
我直接一直到我飞出这个语音的边界
然后在每一个点的话
我去算它的大气的光的通通透和它的散射
那个散射就scattering
而且scattering还要算multiscattering
这个具体在雨里面怎么去算
这个就是那个schattering的话
实际上呢是一个另外一套技术了
这套技术呢其实呃比刚才我讲的那个sky要简单
为什么呢
因为如果我在这边的话
再去做的非常复杂的话
计算机是不允许的
第二个的话呢
语音的话呢
它因为通透度很低
所以呢我们可以做很多大量的这个假设
就是对这个方程进行简化
就像刚才我在讲的那个就是那个最新的虚幻五
做那个就是天空的那个方法嘛
他为什么我个人很喜欢这个方法呢
就是因为他做了很多合理的假设
所以大家以后如果做return rendering的话
一定要大胆假设
所以呢它就可以实现就是real time把这个体积云给绘制出来
所以大家可以理解是你在游戏中看到那个云啊
并不是真实的在天上飘了个面片
它实际上是存在你的gpu里面的一个3d的虚拟的texture
然后我们是用remarking的方法把它解析出来的一个结果
这个想象就抽象
但是呢这个算法本身呢还是比较expensive
所以呢我们一般会用第一的速率的去采样嗯
但是呢这个方法虽然有大量的假设
而且呢听上去呢又有很多noise
但是它实现的效果真的是非常了不起
我给大家看一下它的效果
这就是用这个方法生成的云对吧
它不仅可以模拟很多复杂的云本身的光学现象
还有太阳在语音中间的通透啊
透视这种效果
而且语音本身呢可以模拟各种各样的transition
就是说从薄到厚的
厚到薄的
然后呢各种风吹着它的洞
所以这其实是相对于就是说啊
十几年前的我们的游戏引擎技术来讲的话
是一个革命性的变化
所以今天的游戏引擎这个是属于标配
你必须要做这样的一个语音的效果啊
大家觉得这个怎么样
画面是不是很美
反正我个人是非常喜欢
所以做刚才讲的天空啊
做这个云的话
我们一般称之为叫什么呢
叫天空之神
感觉是不是有神的感觉了
好基本上呢就是哎还好
我基本上勉强控制在两个小时之内
我把今天的课程讲完了
本来我们还有一趴讲fog的
幸好在上课之前
我们临时决定把它给砍掉了
否则发今天的课程就收不了尾了
那么跟大家汇报一下
就是呃我们的polo的引擎现在还在
首先非常感谢大家很积极的参与我们的引擎的这个一起的这个讨论啊
不更新
那这里面的话呢pio引擎的话呢
其实我们在过去的一周还是做了很多很多的工作
就大家修掉了很多的bug
同时的话呢就是说同学们也积极的跟我们做了很多的contribution
这些东西起来
其实我自己这边的话也在想
就是后面可能我们会单独的录一些视频
就是有些同学跟我们讲说
拍的引擎虽然已经很简单了对吧
但是如果我技术比较薄
我没办法不知道从哪下手
我到时候可能会跟大家一起做一个walk through
或者叫123这种视频
跟大家讲一下怎么去看这个pta的引擎代代码
包括我们也希望就是在未来啊
就是在未来的12年里面
我们和大家一起慢慢慢慢的把
刚才我们在课程上讲了一些非常有意思的算法
比如说那个terrain的算法
比如说天空天空的算法
包括云的算法
我们也在我们的小影中
大家一起来实现
我不知道同学们有没有兴趣啊
大家可以在弹幕或者留言告诉我们说
如果大家有兴趣的话
我个人觉得这是很好玩的
帮助大家一起在这样一个这个小引擎里面
把这些前沿的算法都实现得了
这样的话我我们的那个那句话就不是空想了
人均一个对吧
自演引擎
所以po引擎的话呢就是我们的课程组的话跟大家一起去去去干下
去
继续去做
那么另外一个给同学们讲一个就是我们这边的一个思考
就是说啊我们现在发现我们课程的信息量真的是太大了
基本上我们是跟大家去比干那个过程简直就是互相伤害对吧
你们每每周要听到我们这种拖堂的课程
然后那么大的信息量
然后呢课程组也是死去活来
我跟大家分享一下
在过去的72小时
我大概只睡了十个小时
十个小时左右
那怎么说呢
跟大家分享一个我的一个一个一个能力啊
这很像我当年写cio paper的时候的经历
就是我们那时候研究出来的时候
如果你不得不熬夜通宵做东西的时候
最高效的方法是每天凌晨12点到三点休息三小时
这样的话你起来的时候精力是可以充沛的
你可以连续战斗大概4~5天左右
所以在过去的72小时
12小时也就三天的话
我就切换到这个叫每天三小时睡眠的模式
然后才把这个ppt我们团队才干出来
但是这样的话真的是实在难以为继
包括这次我们想到五一长假的时候
我突然发现一个很有意思的事情
就是说我们实际上可以把我们的课程分成一个一个
比如说三四节课成为一个章节
我们每三四节课之后呢
我们休息一周
这样给同学们有时间去消化
去体会
甚至提问
我们也可以给大家做一些简单的视频
给大家讲一些大家关心的问题
然后呢再去讲后面的东西
就是说如果大家没有意见的话
我们后面的话可能按这个方向去去讲
这样的话节奏也会更好一点
另外一个就是呢我们每一节课程准备的时间会更加的充分一点
因为确实作为我们自己来讲的话
既然开了这门课程的话
我们还是态度非常的端正
就今天的这个p p t中的话
每一个公式
每一个符号我们都是检查过的
都是用公式编辑器自己打过的
就真的是推演了一遍
所以公式不要打错了
虽然在课程中我给大家讲说
你不用管它
公式都很简单对吧
但实际上你打开课件的时候
你会发现的公式其实还真的是彼此关联的
那么因为毕竟是作为一门课程嘛
我们特别希望就是说这个前所未有的课程
能够成为同学们真的能够最快速的最高效的理解现代引擎
它的这个前沿
它的全貌的这样的一个一个通识课程
所以的话呢我觉得咱们把节奏控制好
就是每隔几节课休息一下
可能会是一个更好的节奏对吧
就像我们在国外这个一个叫什么semester
就是每隔几周诶
我们有一个小学期停一下
我们休息一下
再去再去那个往后做
基本上我们的作业呢也会采取这种节奏
就是诶三四节课一个小章节
我们布置作业
然后呢留一留一周时间
我们准备下一阶段的课程
大家做作业
这样也节奏也比较好好
那基本上这件事情的话呢
也想征得大家的同意
那个大家如果没有意见的话
我们后面的可能按这个方法去安排好
那就是今天呢我的课程的全部了啊
这个我们好像又创了拖堂的新的记录
现在应该是差不多是接近130分钟了
好的接下来还是留几分钟就给同学们提一下问题
就大家关于今天的课程有什么问题问我
啊这个第一个问题很有意思
同学问我说本节课程讲的四叉式的管理
和前面的课程中那个game objects 4杀四杀数管理是不是可以共用
哎这个同学真的非常的聪明
是的完全可以共用
所以四叉树为什么好
就是它可以把游戏里面的很多东西统一管理起来
就都可以用这种配置的思想
就是可以在硬盘
在那个磁盘到主内存到显存之间来回调度
因为当我们真的做一个像开放世界的游戏的时候
你会发现基本上每个东西都可以把你的显存或者内存给炸掉
好
哦第二对第二个同学的问题是哎呀
这个问题很有意思
他跟我说体积云的渲染会不会耗时啊
是的
刚才其实啊体积云它是它其实在我的理解中啊
它的生成其实还好
因为noise方程大家如果真的写一下
就知道它的效率是非常非常高的
很快你就会在一个morning texture里面
3d的texture里面腐蚀出了一个云的效果
但是当你去做它的渲染的时候
你去做这个remarsh
然后呢你要算它的所有的skettering
虽然这些curing的方程我们都做了很多的简化
你还要把太阳这些东西全部带在一起考虑
而且这个语音呢刚才我没有展开讲
其实那个云的颜色还要受到大气的影响
大家想想看那个远处天边的云
它是不是要从天上这个天光中还要吸吸收阳光
这样看上去才自然
所以这些乱七八糟的东西加上去的时候
你会发现每一个像素你都要做这么多
很奇怪的
因为每个像素就代表了一根锐啊
一根光线
大家如果学过retracing
就知道屏幕上看到每个点就是你的视线射出的一个光线
你都要做这样的一个因素啊
大家想想这是不是要死了
但是呢这里面有很多呃耍流氓的方法
比如说我对屏幕进行down sampling
比如说我只是用1/2的尺寸
也就是1/4的像素算完
然后呢把它进行一个blue
把它贴回去对吧
那么包括那个我们后面可能会给同学们介绍的著名的这个大力水手
dlss s d r s的话
也是能够帮助我们节约很多这样的cos的方法
啊有同学开始跟我抱怨了
这个同学第三回合的问题是说后期课程难度怎么样
会不会完全听不懂啊
是这样的
就是说其实呢我自己的体会啊
rendering应该是最难的一趴哦
我我前两天我在跟林奇就严令奇严老师在讲
我就说哎我们俩课程要联动一下
因为如果在我的四节课中呢
有些东西大家真的听目标的话
我会推荐大家去听他的课
就是说呃其实确实绘制这个东西啊是蛮复杂的
因为它这里面有大量的数学在里面
包括大家刚才也听到了
今天我们就画个天空
我们把整个光学物理学的东西全部给撸了一遍对吧
然后再加上数学又做了一堆简化
还是这么复杂
所以呢但是呢其实如果你真的去做
真的去用的时候
你会发现啊
在这么多前人的工作之上
你真正把它看懂了之后
实现起来其实并不难
那么那么简单来讲的课程难度的话呢
就因为我们在这个rendering这一趴的话
我们一般会跟大家讲一些就是state bar
就是现在真正在用的这些技术
一般来讲一个行业发展了30年之后
它不会太简单
故意很多简单的方法其实都已经被淘汰掉了
他基本上都要求那种很极致的效果
所以的话呢会有渲染难度
那这个课程的话呢
我也会尽可能的把这些复杂的算法
把他的思想
把他的思路教给大家
把一些关键的卡点交给大家
但是的话呢就是说呃
他应该不会影响你对他的宏观的这个思维方式的一个理解
所以后面的难度呢我的预判是会比rendering略微下降一点
这rendering确实是有点难
啊接下来有个同学问我一个问题了
也很很很很专业了
他说这个大气散射计算的终止条件是什么
这个地方的话呢
实际上在我们的实践中
我们就说multisketching
你算到三阶四阶拉
倒不要再算了
再算就死人了对吧
那基本上就是一个硬性的order算的
这并不像物理学说
比如说你的这个电子低于某个值了
我不算了
因为这个是一个非常理论的模型
但是在游戏引擎的实战中的话
我们一般是不敢这么算的
对好的
那今天的话呢
因为我拖堂拖的有点厉害了
已经是这个啊两个小时15分钟了
那要不今天我们先这样
那个再次谢谢大家
就是说参与今天的课程
然后那个希望我们和大家一起把这个课程越做越好好的
那我们下周见
咱们继续比干
继续互相伤害好谢谢大家